[Music]
it what's up guys not to be here all
right
couple things number one yes I'm out
here in California yet again and yes I'm
vlogging number two yes I am wearing
glasses and that's because I am getting
LASIK eye correction surgery on December
10th which involves not wearing my
contacts or we I really gotta learn how
to light for reflections here but that's
gonna be a thing you'll see temporarily
then three yes I am wearing some of the
newest merch it is available now it's
back in the store for the entire holiday
season and if you get it it will ship by
the holiday so that's really exciting so
if you want that link below and for as I
switch hands here I'm out here for the
Tesla pickup truck event this is one of
the few pieces of tech that didn't leak
in 2019 which is actually really
impressive but Tesla's been pretty good
at that same thing happened with the
Roadster so I'm here to see it so if you
want my first impressions of a pickup
truck from someone who doesn't really
use pickup trucks but I'm still curious
about an electric one I'm here for that
I'm doing my best
[Music]
all right so this event was pretty wild
in a lot of ways I feel like it was the
most showy Tesla event in a while you
know they had props they had lasers they
had a just a lot of excited people and
they had an unveiling of a product that
they had kept a secret for awhile a
pickup truck so leave on he gets on
stage he does his intro and pretty
quickly it rolls right out and holy
mother of Batman what the hell is that
that that is not the shape or the look
or any of what I was expecting it looks
like a like a low poly count render of
what the pickup truck is supposed to
look like in a video game like it looks
like one of those fan made renders that
people were making for a month that
you'd say oh it totally doesn't look
like that but here it is I'd say this
reaction from some fellow tech youtubers
I was watching with sums it up pretty
well it was wild okay so there's really
not a whole lot of anything else like it
out on the road so there's some stuff
you can pick up about it from the
livestream and from watching the event
and on the site and there's more to
learn from actually being here so on
stage
Elon went over the cyber trucks
stainless steel exoskeleton which on one
hand sounds really impressive I did a
demo of Franz literally hitting it with
a sledgehammer and not denting it so
that demo went great but also seems very
tricky to work with when the entire body
is this one piece of metal bodywork must
be a nightmare I think but I guess
that's not new for Tesla so the body is
essentially bulletproof but then there's
the windows which they also had some
demos for and they had some bold claims
about how tough it was and they dropped
a heavy metal ball from great heights
onto a sheet of it and it didn't shatter
cool but then they tossed that same ball
lightly at the one actual pickup truck
prototype they have working and both
times the glass broke didn't completely
make it through to be fair but yeah
either this prototype didn't actually
have the super tough glass or they've
got some work to do on that one but then
of course there was this specs which
were really impressive maybe the most
impressive part of the truck so starting
at 40
and dollars for a single motor
rear-wheel drive with a six and a half
second zero to sixty and adaptive
suspension all the way up to a triple
motor all-wheel drive option that goes
zero to 60 in 2.9 seconds and will have
a 500 plus mile range and a 14,000 pound
towing capacity for reference the 2024
f150 can tow about half of that and
that's about all you get from the
presentation you get your numbers it
rolls onstage you see it so it was up to
us to find the pickup truck outside and
learn about as much as we can in person
so I can tell you exactly what I found
from that and basically it is a really
striking truck and it's huge
it really is massive so your boy was
first on line to get a test ride so
literally Franz and his family got out
of the truck as it pulled up with brand
new fixed glass to give us test rides
and I hopped in the front seat for a
quick little one-minute hot lap and yeah
you can tell right away it's very bare
prototype feeling on the interior
there's another yolk steering wheel
similar to the 20/20 roadster prototype
it is basically the same touchscreen as
a model 3 but with new graphics on it
for the cyber truck not sure how final
that is but it looked cool and yeah tons
of glass tons of space lots of headroom
and foot room and you are really high
off the ground you really hiking up to
get into this thing the rear view mirror
if you caught that is a display showing
the rear facing camera and the space in
the middle between the driver and the
passenger is actually a third seat
folded down so it's a six seater three
seats in the front row three seats in
the back and they're both benches so
yeah and you kind of get this like
marble countertop like blank surface
area in the front very strange to me but
yeah that's about all I could tell we
also did a bit of an acceleration test
apparently this is a dual motor variant
and I didn't point the camera at the
speedometer the whole time
I'd say we got up to 60 here's a video I
took later from the outside
so yeah this thing clearly hauls and it
sounds crazy with those tires and all
that weight but yeah it's gonna be
really fast for a pickup truck of course
but yeah I feel like there's just so
much to take in and it's also
unconventional michael fisher said
something to me at the event and he'll
probably have a video about it too with
his thoughts and I'll link that below
when it goes up but one along the lines
of well hey at least we're not bored and
it's kind of funny the more you think
about it the more that is super true
about this truck Tesla could have gone
with a super cookie cutter design and
made it exactly what you'd expect you
know just take an existing Tesla design
and morph it into a pickup truck take a
modern why just cut the back off in fact
I love that that's exactly what Simone
Geerts did with her model 3 in her
incredible video I will link that below
and she had her truck 'la here at the
event but the cyber truck nah yeah that
that cyber truck shares as far as I can
tell pretty much no DNA from any other
Tesla model outside of I guess just the
door handles you know instead of curves
it has angles it looks like the cabin is
a damn triangle the bar headlights are
kind of cool there's also a roof bar
headlight the the tail light is a bar
the wheels are crazy everything is
rethought hopefully for the better and
also I did feel like there's a lot we
still don't know like when does this
come out we didn't get a date but people
can already pre order them and reserve
them and get online
where are the windshield wipers where is
the sideview mirrors what's the bed made
of that ATV that they brought out at the
end and is sort of a one more thing move
that they pulled up and fit in the back
of the cyber truck and charged it in the
back are they selling that to like how
much is that going to be is that an
option with the cyber truck it kind of
looks like a spoiler like the truck
looks better with the ATV in the back
you know there's just a lot to think
about with something where Tesla is
attacking this new market but the way
things go for Tesla you know kind of
like the model why I think we'll start
to see the details creep out a little
bit as they get finalized and closer to
production and as of right now we just
have this massive hype unveiling to get
people talking about it
thinking about it and it's worked and
now we have a big wait but yeah it's
it's one of the most polarizing
automotive designs I have ever seen to
me not a truck person it seems super
badass like the Mars rover type of stuff
I couldn't see myself driving it but it
looks crazy
but if you ask around seems like people
either really like it or really hate it
so I'm curious where do you fall on that
spectrum what do you think about the
cyber truck you can't stay in the middle
you got to pick one either way thanks
for watching this initial first
impressions from the cyber truck event
from Tesla more to come catch you guys
in the next one
bass